- All right, I have one last story I found
that made me smile.
Hopefully you'll feel the same.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
I don't care what age you are,
every person deserves to
have love, companionship
and frankly, a little pampering.
That's exactly what a New York woman
is promoting with her group, Glamour Gals.
For the past two decades,
she's recruited teens
to join her at senior homes.
They hang out with the residents
while also doing their nails,
their hair, little makeovers
that make everybody feel
beautiful on the inside and out.
It's nice.
We have the founder of Glamour Gals
on the line right now
watching on NBC New York.
What's up Rachel?
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Kelly! Hi!
- Hi!
I actually used to do
this with my church group.
Whenever I was a kid,
we used to do something similar to this
and that's how it was introduced to me.
But where did you come up with the idea?
- It's actually in honor
of my own grandmother.
I wanted to give her a beauty makeover,
but she lived in a senior
home across the country
and it just never happened.
So when she passed away,
I wanted to honor her
and so I had this idea of
going into my local senior home
and providing beauty
makeovers to the residents
who live there.
To sit down, to connect, to
share a compliment and a story
and just make someone feel
loved and appreciated.
And it was actually at my first makeover,
I had two friends, just
two friends show up,
but from there, two decades later,
we've inspired thousands of
teen volunteers to do the same
and it's as valuable to them as it's to us
and everybody we serve.
- Yeah, absolutely.
(audience applauding)
So you have a special
holiday project, right?
- That's right.
Absolutely.
Our My Dear Friend Card
Writing Campaign wants to reach
as many seniors as possible.
Anyone can write holiday notes, even kids,
and we pair them with
seniors around the country.
Our goal is to reach
30,000 isolated seniors
with cards this holiday seasons.
So please get writing.
- That's so cool.
I love that.
Even the pen pal thing in general
and I even love how a
kid with a grandparent
kind of aged person,
that's a really cool thing
just to see what would cultivate
from that kind of relationship.
That's a super cool idea.
Thank you so much.
If you wanna be part of
My Dear Friend Cards,
check out our Insta story for info.
You gotta check that out everybody.
Thank you so much for Rachel.
What a beautiful thing you're doing.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I'm liking your posts right now, okay?
(bell dinging)
And that's not all our
season long partner Pilot Pen
makers of G2, the go-to pen
at "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing Glamour Gals
a check for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh!
- That'll help some supplies.
- So much!
- Absolutely.
Thank you Rachel and thank you
to all our guests this hour,
Ubah Hassan, Erin Lichy,
Matt Rogers, Maestro Kyso,
and Jeff Kinney and Jacob.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.